hello and welcome to the seventh episode
of the weekly Google cloud platform
podcast I'm Franciscan boy and I'm here
where you're with my co-host mark Mandel
hi mark
hi Frances Carriere you doing pretty
good pretty good very happy to be here
in San Francisco yeah boating yeah this
beautiful voiceover room yeah it's great
at least the weather's nice here in San
Francisco
reindeer you know it's pretty good yeah
ready for the weekend so what are we
gonna be talking about today mark today
we're gonna talk about cloud messaging
mm interesting it's actually a I quite
like this topic I think it's gonna be a
lot of fun I like it because it's
something that people don't really talk
about because he's not glamorous
yeah but necessary you need it yeah it
is it is quite literally like sort of
the plumbing of the Internet yeah all
right get into that should we talk about
our cool thing of the week sure so the
cool thing of the week I'm sure that
most of our listeners actually might
have seen it already there's some really
cool videos going around is the Google
cloud vision API that sounds pretty
exciting I haven't had a chance to too
much to sit down and look at it have you
so I have not really played with it I've
read the documentation which is
something nice and I played with
something that was built on top of the
API very nice so basically if you've
heard before about tensorflow
which is something that we really is not
that long ago which is basically
revolutionizing how machine learning can
be done like deep learning
neural networks and so on Google has
done a lot of that for quite a long time
we open sourced the way we do that which
is a great thing
it's called tensorflow and even though
it's it's really powerful it's also
quite complicated to use right so what
the what the Google cloud vision API
does it just packages some models some
tensorflow models that already trained
to recognize things on pictures which
are pretty much what we use for google
google photos so I could send
to picture my dog and it would be like
oh that's a dog that's a dog yeah
exactly
ok so it's basically what we use for
Google photos it's exactly the same so
you can send the picture and say and ask
what is this and you're gonna get a
bunch of labels and information about it
so it will be able to say oh yeah that's
a dog but also it could be it could say
something that's a dog next to a cat and
things like that so it's actually really
smart that's really cool okay so I could
do things like facial detection and be
like which person is that I could be
like what logo is it yeah do some ICR
type stuff so character recognition that
sounds like a really powerful thing and
basically I can just like plug and play
with it so I don't know yeah exactly I
don't have to know had this machine
learning stuff works that's a great
thing about it you basically just that
one more API the same way use that you
use the data store you can use now these
service that allows you to discover
what's in a picture so that's great
brilliant I'm having a look here it
looks like if people want to join it's
Carly and limited preview but there is a
form they can sign up for if they want
to get get involved yeah and we will
have that link on the show notes so as
usual most definitely
all right that sounds pretty awesome I
can't wait to sit down and really play
with that and actually the even cooler
thing of the week which is the cool
thing built on top of the cool thing of
the week is something that Brad Abrams
who is a product manager here at Google
oh he did this really cool thing that's
right yeah he did this little game which
is really cool cuz it's a game where you
get a list of words and then you have to
take pictures of things that match those
words so the digital scavenger hunt
basically that's awesome I really loved
it because you can retry and can get new
lists so I got one that it was quite
easy it was like dog and eating and
things like that yeah that was doable
I've also seen and this is actually for
Brad Brad if you're listening to us
putting paranormal creature on a list
like that it's not really helpful I want
to know how they have managed to get the
model to recognize yeah normal creatures
and how many ghosts they had to find -
exactly
I saw that was like go take a picture
over from a creature like nice like it's
like somebody putting Loch Ness on
camera yeah Bigfoot a Yeti like all that
stuff but yeah we'll have a link to the
it's a small Android app so you can give
it a try it's really fun and the good
thing is that the source code is
actually really simple it's basically
just a little API call that's pretty
much it so it's great that's pretty cool
I like that I like that a lot
that's really sweet cool so for our main
content today as you were saying we're
gonna be talking about messaging and the
thumb being of the internet yeah yes
this is something a little bit near
indeed in my heart I quite I quite like
it so we want to talk about like how do
we want to set the stage so generally
this sort of stuff comes up when you
want to do sort of either asynchronous
processing or maybe you have sort of
disparate systems that wouldn't be able
to communicate to each other through
some sort of messaging system also
options are available on Google cloud
platform to let you do that and we'll
sort of like why would you choose one
over another I think to set the stage I
think really we're sort of looking at
two particular pieces one of which is
task queues have been around for a long
time they've been an app engine and
something that's relatively newer it
Shore at least relatively new released
publicly as is cloud pub/sub the racers
are pretty exciting so I think we'll end
up talking about both of those if you
have you worked for those I've
definitely used I've definitely use task
queues before yes queues have been
around for a very long time so I've used
it for for many demos that I've done
yeah
and it's really simple to use it's
beautiful it's very willing to great
with App Engine so if you're doing App
Engine it's probably the way to go with
it and then I also use pops up in my
last demo the Google cloud spin oh it is
this pops up to communicate to send
tasks across all the workers oh yeah so
why don't we what am I so explain what
both of them are and we can sort of
continuum from there okay so since I
I've used tasks use more for it I will
explain what task uses basically task is
are just a very very basic
implementation and by basic I mean very
simple to use and break it down to earth
is nothing really fancy basically what
you can do is you have queues yeah and
these queues you can think about them
like pipes like Linux pipes or like just
a
first in first out okay
on the cloud yeah where you can send
messages on one side and then on the
other side you can receive them yeah and
you have two ways of doing that so
sending those messages can be done
through a REST API or directly from App
Engine you have some even yeah you have
a very nice client that you can use very
easily and then on the other side the
way you receive them you have two
choices one is what we call a pool task
and a pool task is basically when you're
asking okay I'm ready to receive a task
give me one task yep and once you're
done free train that task you say
another message which is an
acknowledgement saying hey I'm done with
that task you're gonna be you can delete
it
yeah that way that's actually really
powerful because that way if for some
reason you start trading that task and
for some reason yeah the machine just
crashes you don't lose that desk it can
throw me try yeah it will retry later
yeah after some time out time that we
have so that's that's very simple it's
very often what you want you can also
have something which is the opposite way
rather than the workers asking for a new
task is actually the the task it's the
the test being sent directly to the
workers yeah
and that works really well if you have
for instance something like some kind of
load balancer and a bunch of machines
behind actually like App Engine using
App Engine App Engine it works really
well yeah but then you still have the
fact that if you try to send that task
and you respond to that task with
something else that 200 or 202 like this
again okay it should be good then that
that's where we retry it lay around yeah
and where we try things there's always
this exponential backup yeah one of it
out one of the things I really like
about task queues is as a configuration
file - yamo file like everything we
always do that allows you to say how
quickly and how often you want you want
things to get processed and also you
have a lot of control over how you want
to retry like how many times we're gonna
back off you know all that stuff so you
have a lot of control over all the tasks
using
and you can have more than one it's it's
yeah as many tasks as you want and the
other thing I really like about task
queues with push tasks specifically you
can defer them for later yeah which is
really nice - you're like you want to
run this in half an hour or you want to
run this next day or something like that
you know but do it sort of is a one-off
thing that's that's also quite powerful
it's pretty it's pretty nice yeah I've
seen it I've seen it used very often for
two different use cases that come
they're very different but work very
well with tasks use yeah the first one
being you have some list of things that
you have to do like imagine for instance
you have some forum and you have to
moderate the new posts oh yes pause you
can put them in inside of a task queue
yep and then the job like the webpage
itself and maybe even JavaScript you can
access give me the next task you
presented and then you have everything
just down there so it's very simple to
do and it works very well with a with a
full mode and the other one is when you
want to do something a little bit later
because that way your requests will
finish faster yeah so like a performance
increase that makes a lot yes so for
instance if you have something where you
receive a mad request yeah as a result
of that request you have to send an
email sending an email might take some
time so you don't maybe have some
attachments or something yeah you maybe
you need to go find some images or
something like that so it's very often
it's better what you want to do is just
to create that task and say that will be
done as soon as possible but not right
now
and then just return at your hundred to
the customer yeah that makes a lot of
sense that's a lot of sense alright cool
so so task you sound pretty powerful to
sound like think that they've got a lot
of really great features so I guess it
falls on me to talk about pub/sub I
think so yeah right so I've worked with
pops up before pops up is pretty much
actually exactly as he explained like if
anyone's looked at the software patent
of publish/subscribe yeah it is it is
exactly that so you have publishers
which can send out messages and they
send those messages to topics and this
is exactly what it's called inside pops
up
those topics essentially everything
about pub/sub is HTTP which i think is
great makes things really simple it's
actually specifically over HTTP so it's
secure
so publishers can push messages there
Jason packets straight to topics that
can be created any number of publishers
that is and then any number of
subscribers can subscribe to those
topics and get those messages so you can
do like fan in fan out so many to one
one to many all that sort of good stuff
so you can build some really nice
decoupled architecture very much like
what you can do with with task queues
but you have this opportunity here where
you can have many people listening or
many subscribers listening to a single
message which you can't do it yeah
that's very nice basically with with
pub/sub you're able to do like broadcast
yes and you cannot really do that with
yeah that's right yeah so it gives you a
little bit more flexibility that way
they're really cool about this thing
about this while it is sort of
relatively new as well it's pretty
battle-tested like I actually started
using it way back when when it first
came out and it was really new but it
was rock-solid basically it's because
it's the same thing that powers things
like ads in hangouts we the nearside
Google and you know anything that powers
ads inside Google like that has to work
much like and much like tusks use you
know it's it's guaranteed to be at least
once to show up yeah that's persistent
storage that's actually very important
it will not happen very often that you
receive the same task twice I don't
think I've ever seen it but it kind of
it I'm listening that you should be
ready for that happening so it's
important to be able to to trade second
requests as just not important you can
either ignore it or you do the treatment
twice but that doesn't take you into a
wrong State yeah make sure it's that
important make sure exactly that's the
word I hadn't thought and yeah so yeah
that's super important it's also worth
noting as well pops up also again like
you can with tasks use a lot of
similarities here you can do both push
and pull from the app might ask use so
you might use push when you want to send
it directly to somebody who's receipt
who needs to receive it that's as far as
an HTTP requests with the data straight
in it but then also you can
pull requests as well so you can say I
want to grab the last 10 or 15 what's
the max number no and it sends it down
that can be quite useful if you don't
want to be order scaling all the time
you know you want to say like I've got
three machines and I just want to keep
it going
but the nice thing is is it has
integration with cloud monitoring yeah
so if you want to sort of do some auto
scaling based on how much stuff is in
your pub sub-q or in your pops up topic
I should say you can do that and it
works that integration is quite nice
yeah and that's something that you can
do out of the box with task queues it's
something that maybe you could implement
but is definitely not as simple to do as
with yeah yeah yeah but the other flip
side is task queues give you all the
knobs to sort of sort of play with to
say like I want to go faster here or
back off more there whereas pops-up is
more rudimentary it has that sort of
retry mechanisms yeah but it's just sort
of like this is the way it works it
doesn't you don't have like oh I want it
to back off once and then go back you
know 10 seconds and 15 yeah any you know
it's kind of like you're on your own pub
subs time on how that works that's where
the desk is give you more more
fine-grain tuning yeah and there's
things that are actually quite
interesting for instance you can
actually have throttling for you can say
in this task which is only for push
tasks though yes if you're the poor it
doesn't matter
as soon as soon as you pull yeah new
tasks but when you do push task you
could say oh yeah I don't want to send
more than ten messages per second and
this can be really powerful because if
you have a traffic peak your task you
will just moderate that traffic Pete
yeah it just keep the task for a little
bit later yeah so your users will will
experience some lag but your system will
continue working with that any glitch
yeah whereas weave pops up if you wanted
to do that you'd have to do it as a pool
cue
yeah you'd have to sort of regulate it
yourself and say this is how often I
want to I want to be processing each
message the other the other thing with
pubs up regardless of whether you do
push up home you have to send back an
ACK message you have to like acknowledge
that you've done that's that's really
important and it's kind of like it's a
bit simpler that way I don't know maybe
in my mind so regardless of whether you
push your pool as long as
once you're done you have to say hey I'm
done with it you specify deadlines with
it so you're like this is how long I
think it's gonna take when you set up
everything but then once you say ACK
it's like how cool I'll delete it now
I'm good to go otherwise yeah then you
know that retry mechanism and and
everything works from there but yeah I
mean one thing I just I really love
about pub/sub is that it doesn't require
any special type of transport layer so
you don't need any like custom clients
you're not need to be talking every
special sockets or anything like that
it's all HTTP it's little Jason packets
yeah it's a little pretty much plain
text over the wire so anything can talk
that which is pretty much anything
that's great and so then you can do in a
communication between whatever you like
yeah and it's really flexible and you
never you know if you want to add
something extra so like for example
that's a great example I'm thinking of
so you want to do something Tosca which
for example you're talking about so you
were doing like I want to process this
image later so you could put that into a
pub sub topic much like a couplet ah
scuse but then maybe later on you're
like oh what I also want to do is I want
to log every time I do that as well yeah
so then you go okay that's fine I will
just add another subscription to my pub
sub thing same thing don't have to
change any of my other code and then I'm
like oh I've just got another listener
to this particular topic when the image
comes in and then I'll log in and then
maybe you're like oh actually I will so
I want to do this other thing with an
image and you can continue on from there
and that's that's a really powerful
medium I think yeah the Tsarina is the
fact that you can basically have a much
much generic architecture where you can
add stuff with a modifying any code yeah
that's really powerful
it's receiver powerful what you were
saying about yeah there's no specific
transport that is required when it's
just like HTTP HTTP with Jason yeah
that's actually also the case for so
yeah something really important which we
have done mentioned which is there's
absolutely nothing that you need to do
to get pops up or desk is working I give
the need to install anything that's true
you need to manage anything it's fully
managed services that
power of Google cloud so yeah if you
need to use them you just start using
them that's it that's it nothing to be
up no that's that's a really good point
let me do through sort of like some of
the feature comparisons between the two
so people get a bit of an idea of maybe
like
which bits they might want to use in
their application for what because there
are there is a lot of overlap there
we're gonna put this at a table up in
the show notes yeah franceska is not any
grease I mean good so like yeah so we
can sort it you can dig into it further
but I think it's it's worth going into
because yeah there is overlap I can see
why people be like oh I'm gonna go this
way go that way I can think of what my
rule of thumb might be maybe it's
different from your rule of thumb but
you'll have to say it so I can excel I
probably lean more to what's pub/sub
these days then tuskys interesting just
because it allows you more flexibility
to add extra things to it yeah but I do
put some caveats on that in terms of
like if you do need that fine-grained
control over processing speed or retries
Kreuger task queues you could also just
do pull requests and pops up yeah so for
me it's a little bit different for me
depends on what I'm doing if I'm
building an app engine app yeah task
queues is very well integrated with it
that's true so I will probably go with
task queues if I'm not using tasks I've
done using App Engine if I'm doing
something on compute engine which is my
own code or especially if it's involving
something which is not public cloud like
Internet of Things and you have many
devices that are around yeah
like communication with those over over
pops up there's going to be much much
better to do then exit one little thing
which is if you need something there's
something that pops up doesn't offer
that tasks you does which is do things
in half an hour that is true and that is
true that yes that can be quite quite
powerful quite powerful like you can do
something like oh yeah I'm receiving
this this request yeah check in half an
hour if this happen if you didn't happen
do these other thing I've worked it out
you create a task queue that then
creates a pub/sub message yeah
probably okay maybe yeah you could do it
really depends again you probably need
simplicity as well but that's no that's
fair enough no that's cool and there's
one other cute trick that task queues do
that we actually I'll be devil's
advocate against myself if you're on App
Engine you can do transactions within
datastore that wrap around your toss
cubes that's very powerful which is
quite cool so if you're like I'm gonna
put some data in data store and then I
want to create a task basically against
that data you can wrap that up in a
transaction so that they're they're one
in the same so if one of them if it
fails you know it will fall Sam yeah you
could probably replicate it using pups
up and hard that'd be quite hard yeah
you could probably do it in some ways
like chicken but the fact that those are
integrated quite nicely together yeah
that's very nice it's pretty cool it is
pretty cool all right we mentioned the
feature matrix before we went off there
okay yeah cool so the first feature is
you can pull and push via now pull via
API yes yeah which is around REST API
will have clients but yeah yeah both the
student pops up what about pushing via
web hooks actually pushing to web
basically yes they both have that they
will have bad and their one condition
which is HTTP yes which is always like
you should always do that anyway but
yeah what about the size of every single
message they can send so that's an
interesting one so task queues have a
limit of a hundred K per message okay
pups UPS a little bit more interesting
it's actually a ten megabytes per
publish request but you can send up to a
thousand messages within that request
so you could send a thousand messages
and every single message could have 1000
real I did the math one case something
like this one Meg yeah yeah I think that
math yes you could do that or you could
say one message that is up to ten
megabytes okay so you kind of have some
flexibility there which is pretty cool
it's important to tell that that
even though you can send 10 Meg's pops
up and tasks use and general messaging
systems are not really built to handle
really big size yeah probably should
like store big data somewhere persistent
like yeah hard your datastore cloud see
yeah and that's around just the path to
that yeah bet it's much better than just
sending big files inside like that's not
a very good idea
yeah I what about the delivery guarantee
I am assured that I will receive those
messages I would hope so yeah and again
the little difference it's you will
receive that message and probably only
once but maybe you might receive it
twice so your actions should be as
important just in case that that arrives
yeah we have batch inserts so being able
to insert more than one more more than
one desk or message at a time can you do
that you can only do that in App Engine
which is interesting
so the REST API so if you're outside a
App Engine you want to use the REST API
you can only send one task at a time dad
being for desk use okay but I'm pub/sub
you can do whatever you want yeah so
don't there's no mutation there there's
well you have to send it's under ten
megabytes and up to a thousand messages
yeah but yeah you can send as many
messages as you regardless of where
you're sending them from can you have
multiple receivers so in a task queue if
you create only one task you and I send
one message how many times will that
message we received okay just once just
once that yeah but I don't pops up
there's actually not that limitation
either cuz it will receive ones for
subscription yeah and you can add more
subscription per topic yesterday it
basically you can have you have a little
bit of best of both worlds where you can
have per subscription it will receive by
only one of the receivers topics can
have up to ten thousand subscriptions
which is quite big yes seems reasonable
amount it's in yeah yeah thousand yeah I
don't think I've ever done something
with that many machines
well other than when I was working for
ads there you go
what about the maximum number of
messages per second you say you were
looking at this for tasks use yeah do
you want
explain that okay so I'm gonna go first
with pops up there's no limit there's no
limit I just go for it there's not a
minute dad yeah just go go crazy with
that we ask you is there's the
limitation which is first you have to
activate billing if you have the billing
activated that won't work
but then you can go up to 1 billion
messages per day which is quite big
reasonable yeah and the recommendation
is you should not go over like 250
messages per second per cube so you have
multiple queues that doesn't really come
so you can kind of shard it yeah you can
start over me okay this seems to handle
I think probably most people's load yeah
if you have then like 1 billion messages
per day I have not made the maps to be a
managed messages per second but the loss
I go with a let's go let's go with a lot
so we're talking about throttling before
so yeah task queues has built-in
throttling so you have control with net
that yeah mph on for push queues for
push queues yeah because you always do
pull and sort of control it yourself
yeah so with pub/sub if you're gonna do
throttling you need to sort of do it
yourself yeah which is actually not that
complicated I've done it before
basically what you do is every single
receiver every single worker able to
sleep for like two seconds before going
for the next task that's it that's it
that's it or you could just keep it
going like if you're just happy I mean
you're getting for the machine anyway
like you've got on a VM you might just
keep turning
yeah there's stuff yes but you don't
need to do anything special really
wonderful
now performance so the performance it's
quite interesting because it really
depends on what you're trying to do I'm
gonna go first with pops up we actually
have a link to that which is you will
get sub second times normally you will
get like milliseconds on both tasks you
Sam pops up yeah but um pops up you'll
get even less than less than a second
even when you send me more than 1
million messages per second that's
pretty good that's really good actually
that that means that it scales really
really well
well the powers ads and hangouts I mean
it has to do right yeah so so that's the
thing pops up will scale like like
like you can just go for it and and
there will be a little bit of a
degradation but it will never go up over
one second which is actually quite easy
yeah on task is though the scalability
won't be that big so if you trying to
send that many messages probably pops up
could be a so if you're doing big data
yeah with a bunch like imagine you have
sensors in know every every place ever
and those sensors are actually sending
data all the time yes coming in yeah
probably pops up is tomato and finally
we also mentioned cloud monitoring so
plum miring as we said pops up allows
you to have monitoring measures so you
can do things based on that alerts and
all the things like I forgot so if you
wanted to throttle or you wanted to
order scale a lot of scales daughter
scale you can do that based on the
number of messages you know actually
like the idea as well as doing alerts
that's kind of cool like if you hit past
a certain point
Zoid that or you can do it the other way
around you can say like if we're getting
less than 100 messages per second
something's wrong so just let me know
and you can do that very easily yeah I'm
from the Monterey can you do that with
tasks use you could do it manually it's
not there's no there's not a thing that
that's that great okay yeah you if you
if you really want to do tasks use and
the only limitation that you're on is I
go back to have muttering you could
build it on top of that there's not such
a limitation but you have to build it
okay yeah enough all right great well I
think that probably covers that topic
quite simply if you got anything else
you can think of not really I think that
we've talked about messaging and now for
today we've yeah but if there's anyone
that has questions about hey in front of
the days is it better to do task queues
or pops up I let us know what you're
doing and we're here to help you yeah
hello at GCP podcast comm it is up on
twitter GCP podcast the reddit we have a
subreddit our
HSP podcast and also plus GCP podcast on
google plus as well yeah cool um okay so
great before we go what is the question
of the week today question of the week
has to do with looking data interesting
so I I look I I think it's interesting
logging dater is like the bread and
butter it's like the core of anything
you do you need to know what your
application is doing like it's
super-important it's even less glamorous
the messaging but even more important
probably probably yeah so you know
Google cloud platform has integrated
logging platform like it allows you to
do some viewing it's really awesome but
we tend to only hang around to it for a
limited amount of time you can configure
it and say like when do you want to drop
data off and what sort of fun stuff but
what happens if you want to like store
your logs for all time right maybe you
want to do some big data analytics later
on or you just need it for auditing
purposes or who knows like there's so
many so many things you could do is
there an easy way to do it I know there
is there is I've never done it so I'm
gonna let you answer that question so I
love this this is this got me so excited
when this came out so if you go into the
logging section and above it you should
see in the developer console in there in
our in our web admin there's a section
called logs you go in there and you'll
also see another thing called exports
which is super cool so you can go in
there you can select the service that
you want to export and then you
basically have a one-click send it to
like a Google Cloud Storage bucket if
you just want to store it for a real
long time and with it but you can also
send it to bigquery and you can also
send it to would you believe it pops up
amazing
so if anyone I like just stick it in a
Google Cloud Storage bucket and then do
something with it later you don't know
what you want to do that's fine if
you're already doing analytics on it
especially maybe if you're doing say if
you've got structured logs in Jason
that's really powerful so you can send
it straight to bigquery and stream it
straight in so you do analytics on the
fly and then if you want to do really
crazy messaging stuff with it
you can send it to pub/sub which can
then go to any number of other places
from there as well yeah that's actually
ones you
once you have it on pops up you can do
whatever you want with it crazy yeah you
already have it you can create your
subscriptions and we actually didn't
mention it but pops up integrates
directly with dataflow I wanna have a
big data product so if you wanted your
logs to be starting to go through data
flow as well that could be a really
interesting way of getting all that data
to flow through it yeah which is
actually we will be doing an episode
sometime soon about all the big data
products that we have wonderful so we're
gonna be covering bigquery data flow and
so on and all of those integrate
amazingly well with pops up because
that's a way to go that's pretty awesome
I don't know too much about big data
stuff so I'm looking forward to that I'm
gonna learn a whole lot that's gonna be
fun yeah wonderful so it is the end of
the year we keep talking about it I
believe you're just going off to
holidays I'm going to holidays yeah in a
couple weeks one sided and we will
actually have a break will we we will
next week should be our last episode for
the year
and then we'll be breaking until next
year yeah so what they know yeah it will
be always definitely be back on a
Wednesday it will be earlier
Yallah Jenner it will definitely be back
again I will be a dev fest in a few
weeks the 12th and 13th of December in
Vancouver I am excited about a winter in
Vancouver yeah which is gonna be great
fun and then will be I think I think
I'll be at home I'll be at home pretty
much I think is my plan nice for the
break yeah I won't be traveling until
the break I will be going for holidays
in a private location so that's gonna be
lots of fun too
so anyway lots of fun talking about this
topic today with you Mark lots of fun
talking with you and see you all next
week
see you next week